good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
happy friday friday gotta get down on
friday
that's exactly what i have to do i've
got to get down on friday
but not before the morning toast this is
going to be a very long show because we
have so much we have much
to discuss lots happened yesterday the
world was turning you know faster than
ever which you know you'd love to see it
but then we finally are going to have
our part two of selling sunset recap
the real housewives of new york finale
was uh came to a close last night
and i started the vow on netflix i mean
no no hbo
max and to be honest i don't really feel
like i need a whole lot to say about it
i feel
and i'm only episode two and so maybe
i'll have more to say when we come back
next week
but i feel the exact same way about
nexium that i did that when we watched
the
true hollywood story like losers
were involved like they keep trying to
make it seem like it was a celebrity
like thing hollywood hollywood
and their biggest claim to fame is that
they held an event once on
richard branson's island like but he
wasn't a part of the cult like that's
what's important to remember like
allison mack was the most famous one and
you never heard of her before an axiom
so just
sip on that great love to hear it glad
to finally get a word in good morning
everyone happy friday
glad to hear that you're watching some
interesting content yes we have so much
to
discuss today thco is here so we have
his expert opinion
because there are some matters that need
his level of
expert jesus teas so
it's going to be just a great friday i
can't believe we're here i feel so
hashtag blessed i feel accomplished i
love making it
like proud joyful everything of the sort
to be here on this friday
even though it's our last show before
the ykb oh my god i forgot so yes
this is the last time you'll see us
before we are repented
queens programming update we will be
back next week starting
tuesday and you think you're upset
there's an episode of the morning toast
at least you won't be fasting maybe you
will but maybe not it's like a double
whammy you're fasting
and there's no toast yeah it's really
upsetting
um so monday we'll be repenting for our
sins and then we'll see you back here on
tuesday just to do them all over again
yes to start sinning all over again and
then also speaking of
judaism after this episode we are going
to record our latest patreon episode
which is
you know a sequel to an episode we did a
while ago that was very popular i think
we did it like a year ago
yeah um around this time because it's
it's a big time for the jews right we
always get a lot of questions about like
judaism like from
fellow jews and from people who've like
never met you in their life so we're
doing a whole jewish
podcast patreon episode answering
people's questions common faqs you know
um from people so that'll be on our
patreon and it's truly never been a
better time to sign up for the morning
just patreon
never ever been a better time also my
sweater today is from zara so i really
do i finished out the week like full
zara strong you wore zara to dinner last
night
i wore zara to dinner last night and a
different item that i've worn on the
show
this week so i kept good on my promise
it's been a zara filled week and i'm
happy to finish strong
this is the sweatshirt i was talking
about where it's like this waistband is
tight
i hate that and it's like go it's
cropping a little high but
i just keep pulling it down yeah um so
i'm excited i feel like we should just
dive right in because there's so much to
tackle
okay we could do that i don't really
have anything else to say except that we
went to dinner last night
and if you're ever in you know the new
york area and you're looking for a great
outdoor dining experience quality bistro
was fabulous it was really
really good we also just had such a nice
time like great conversation
drinks like i feel like i ate my food
and i didn't even like pay attention to
it because we were just like chatting
and chatting yeah like honestly my meal
was like a six out of ten but like i
didn't mind because first of all
the ambiance was beautiful it felt very
clean like some of the outdoor dining is
like you're literally eating in the
sewer but
it was very elevated the drinks were
great the company was great the service
was great
it was really like a 10 out of 10
experience it really really was we also
recorded the redheads yesterday so that
will be available to you
next week another fabulous episode with
the fabulous group of gals i expect
nothing less from the redheads than
fabulosity
yeah no the redheads they deliver they
really do so they're
they're not like digiorno they deliver
so we're going to deliver
yes the fast side stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast
um i spoke to the doctor she said i'm
probably all good to go into the weekend
without any symptoms so i have nothing
to say tonight oh my gosh it's so
exciting it's good news
it is okay well it's actually bad news
ultimately ultimately like we need to
pay our medical bills
but the first story is one of the big
stories of the day demi lovato and max
eric split two months after his proposal
after a whirlwind romance and engagement
demi lovato and fiance max eric have
called it quits according to multiple
sources the couple who got engaged in
july
and celebrated their six-month dating
anniversary earlier this year
started having problems over the last
several weeks as they returned to work
after quarantine together in la amid the
pandemic why would that be hard max
doesn't have a job
i think he is on a soap opera actually
the people who work on soap operas are
very busy
and from what i understand in this
twitter thread that i read
yeah we'll get into he's working in
atlanta right now and she actually went
there to be with him and be supportive
and that's where things fell into
disarray
so you sent me this twitter thread last
night but i've been here i didn't
oh i guess it was snitching i thought it
was you oh no margo sent it in our group
chat
margot sent it but i have even before
that like stan twitter
hated max because he's kind of been like
a hanger honor like
star [ __ ] for like the last couple of
years and there's so many screenshots of
him like being obsessed with selena
gomez
commenting on all these celebrities
instagrams like he's so
desperate he's like really what you in
hollywood you call like a wannabe star
[ __ ] and like
he really he got pretty far because he
got engaged to demi lovato and i'm sure
that like his desperation had something
to do with the fact
the reason why she broke up with him
yeah when i first heard the story that
they broke up
i was like kind of sad because i really
want happiness for demi lovato and i
thought that she had found that
and then i saw this twitter thread and
desperate it was so
like now it all makes sense to me
there's not a piece of the story that i
don't understand i think demi lovato
must be an extremely trusting optimistic
person
and let this person into her life and
later found out that like he
was using her to get to selena gomez
using her and really just wanting to
marry like a celebrity
and i just can't believe that this guy
got this far and then [ __ ] it up
yeah because this is an ambitious guy
who's like so
driven to marry a celebrity and he was
so close and like
i don't know what you guys were fighting
about but like i can't believe he
couldn't like let it go
make her happy like yeah because he
wanted it so badly but i'm so glad that
like whatever happened that she saw
through
this because it is so clear that he
is using her you know what i was
thinking about last night when i was
thinking about how he
she's being used what and that he's
committing misery
you three yeah we were playing cards
against humanity
we had a pack that was um also like a
jewish pack but we were playing with the
regular pack and
the word usury was a card but i thought
it was part of the jewish pack and it
was usury and i didn't know what it was
it was an alternative pronunciation of
our last name
and i was like showing it i'm like you
think you have a bad card
wait quickly back to demi lovato um i
agreed that when i heard it like
i was sad for demi but like to be honest
i feel like this relationship from the
announcement
to like all the content and just like
everything about it was so strange
and i actually wasn't sad that it was
over like okay demi lovato was a little
bit further away from like her fairy
tale ending but like
it would have been horrible if she went
through with this like something about
and i didn't want to be a [ __ ] when we
were like reporting on the engagement
like something about the whole thing was
so
fake and phony and like green screen
about it like it was just
so wrong and i'm like wow this girl
really wants a boyfriend okay so she got
one and she got this freak
but to be honest um i didn't see like
that i had no idea oh i did
i really was so naive and i was hopeful
i know that they only dated for
like six months in total but you know i
was hopeful that that just meant that
the love was so strong in there because
that happens too and
and of course and i had no idea who this
person was and that he was like a
professional instagram commenter i don't
know who verified him
and how he even has like a career i have
a really fun fact for you about max
okay you know this whole time i thought
it was earlier i know you said that when
they got engaged too oh yeah
i thought i pronounced it wrong yeah um
it's actually mac us three
do you know at one point in time like
fairly recently maybe like a year ago
max irish was pitched to be on the toast
and we said no
wow i love us yeah but that was
obviously before he was dating tim
lovato because i would have said yeah
oh for sure that's so crazy yeah i had
no idea who this man was
and now it's very clear to me what's
been going on and i'm happy that
that demi saw the light i hope i don't
sound ridiculous but i don't know who
this man
is yeah i'm sorry to this man wait i
actually recently saw the full
[ __ ] version of the video do you know
what she's talking about
yes it's iconic literally i thought she
was like acting in that video but it was
like a w
magazine like funny like schtick youtube
video and
they put up a picture of dick cheney and
like she really didn't know who he was
he was like i'm
i hope i don't sound ridiculous but i
don't know who this man is that's the
best
the best video ever i'm not sorry to
this man though like
i'm sorry to demi lovato that i just
like i feel for her my heart goes out to
her because
we know that she's been through so much
i think that ultimately what she really
wants is love and a relationship and
it's clear in the fact that she accepted
a proposal like
from africa
but it's just it's not her time and like
i feel really sad for her you know what
she's just one of those girls who like
wants like love in a fairy tale so bad
that like
she'll almost do anything she can to get
it yeah and that's
that's not where you want to be no
that's not where you want to be i don't
know i feel like when we watch these
documentaries about demi like she's
always talking in hindsight about like
these people that she surrounded herself
with who was drilling holes into her
head
can you guys hear the construction
because it's it's as if the window is
wide open
literally is it fine in the audio
also we haven't spoken about how like
the people on the roof
behind jackie on the show we need to
give them credit it's
so funny literally every time i watch a
show and they switch to jackie's like
one camera
and on the roof behind her like out the
window there's
always like construction going on so you
could see like people some beauties
it's like i'm sure one day we'll get
like their daughters are gonna see it
and and then they're gonna come out with
signs yeah this is uh
like gma has um an audience on the
sidewalk
and we have those guys and the
construction out the window
yeah it's exciting i bet you know what
sometimes you can't hear it so we'll try
not to harp on it
all right so debbie lovato and max are
no more and you know
the only person really devastated is
obviously max oh yeah for sure he came
so close to the dream
and for demi like i'm happy for you
that you said
even if i can't
understand oh that was good i liked that
little
run at the end that was nice so demi we
love you
this is for the best we love you this is
for the best
my reputation has never been worse so
you must like him for him yeah okay
next story some this this whole episode
is about baby news you guys so
gertier loins princess eugenie is
pregnant the royal is expecting her
first child with husband jack
brooksbank is that the one who got
married before beatrice
i mean well yes no before the kovid
wedding yes she had a real royal wedding
okay right right and she was the
snatcher
they look so similar and they're like
not twins they're just like really like
sisters who look a lot alike
can't relate and i just can never tell
them apart
i treat them like they're twins like
which twin are you they're like the
oppenheims
yes but the oppenheimers are twins you
know they're women's jokes
they're roommates no this is really
sweet level good royal baby news
yeah and so who will this baby be to the
queen
great grandchild that is so crazy her
ninth great-grandchild
what a legacy what a legacy crazy times
happy for them all we're just going to
plow right through this because i'm also
happy for billy lord who is a mom the
actress has welcomed her first child
with fiance austin rydell this was sweet
she posted a picture on instagram
um i like billy lord i mean she's kind
of low-key now i feel like for a while
like during the screen queens era she
was like super like out and about
but now she's kind of low-key and i just
love when people you know
of like evolve you know and she's like a
mom now and it's just beautiful she
posted a picture of bibby's feet it's
got a big fruit
but i thought the same thing i'm like
damn these are big feet you know what i
think it is that's why
it's because when like we met michaela
she was like small
and so now i see these but also it's
like when i saw pictures of magnolia
before i met her
i thought she was like a full-sized dog
and then i saw her in person and she was
like the smallest thing i ever saw
so sometimes like the pictures when it's
just a food on its own like you don't
see it to scale
or maybe the baby just has big feet
maybe the baby's gonna be a basketball
player the next michael jordan
maybe anyways baby's name is kingston
fisher lord rydell
well that's a lot of names stating it
reminds me of greece kingston
fisher lord rydell right fisher debbie
fisher
billy lord rydell is him kingston is his
name
that's a nice name i've heard worse
celebrity names this is very like a
blogger you know you know that meme
about like all the blogger
baby names like spelled weird like lo
lo whatever like this reminds me of that
oh got it like kaelin
right right right raylan i don't think
so kingston
kingston it's thecube i'm sorry there's
only one kingston
sean i agree and mandy moore is pregnant
expecting a
boy with her husband taylor goldsmith i
didn't even know she was married
there are certain celebrities who like i
like and like i just couldn't
like care less about their personal life
i feel like manny moore is one of them i
appreciate her love her work
i really like mandy moore but
unfortunately like her participation in
this is us
has made me dislike her i could not
agree more and here's the thing about
this is us like i just have a bone to
pick with it
i don't i've never seen it i know that i
wouldn't like it you would
hate it and like i felt pretty certain
about that
and then i watched selling sunset and i
feel more certain about it
that like no no see this is what i
always say
there are two types of people in this
world and there are people who think
that this is us is inspiring and people
who think it's like dumb and stupid
and there's just there's nothing wrong
with either group there's just
two totally different people i watched
the first season it's not like i didn't
give it a try
it is just so [ __ ] corny and like the
fact
you know what anything bothers me about
it too the way that like e news writes
up about like milo ventimiglia
and like mandy moore like you will die
at their romance what happened to jack
like the way they talk about them i
think is what makes me hate the show
even more and caused me to stop watching
so i don't know if the actual show just
sucks or the way that people act like
the show is like the cure for cancer
yeah and that like every week we're
going to cry
it's just so corny and tacky like
and i know i'm probably offending a lot
of people but that's what i do here at
the morning shows and people probably
love it like tune in every
weekend weekend whatever day monday with
their girlfriends and it's just like
you would have to tie me down and get me
to watch another minute of that show and
it's not like i didn't try
yeah no like i want the show to end no
so badly like i want it to fail
no like i just wanted to finish like
please you had your fun
all the shows that i love like three
seasons smack
shrimp like these shows like just ends
they go on forever they go on forever i
just can't
so anyways i'm really happy for mandy
moore though me too she's a sweet girl
baby boy goldsmith is coming early 2021
is her husband's jewish goldsmith
i have to guess goldsmith yeah
so we'd love to see it love to see it so
many i mean this is really now the
byproduct of quarantine
yes so many babies no being conceived
being born and you know what
it's not a bad problem to have no not a
bad problem to have a very exciting time
and lots of baby news what can we say
lots of
moira rose is just celebrating yeah she
is
happy yes she's a happy woman okay our
fifth and final story is really one of
the craziest stories i've ever heard
that i felt like i needed to share with
the class
um it's like a weird news story but i
just wanted to switch it up
okay a police raid in vietnam finds more
than 300 000
used condoms i saw this being packed for
resale washed and packed in their
defense
excuse me excuse me
i'm just saying you gotta get the
package okay police in vietnam said they
found about 320 000
recycled used condoms that were being
repackaged as new
local media reported on thursday market
inspectors in bing wang province raided
a factory
near ho chi minh city where they
discovered used condoms being repackaged
to be sold at the market
an inspector said the factory's 34 year
old owner a woman confessed they
purchased the
condoms from someone else after buying
the condoms from a man they were washed
and reshaped
then packed in plastic bags according to
the newspaper
i mean this is so vile
first of all just like the of course
like the hygiene of it is so disgusting
and then like scamming people do you
know what people do with condoms like
they put them of course like on their
penises but they
they do other things with them too like
they just frolic around they go in
different orifices like
it's so [ __ ] disgusting like this is
literally like a
human rights violation the u.n should
get involved
i completely agree it's one of the most
disturbing things i think i've
ever heard no i completely agree sick
these people are just trying to you know
have safe sex and be responsible
and i can't even imagine what sort of
communicable diseases are being passed
around
those used condoms yeah vtv said it was
unclear how many condoms were already
resold
oh my god that's just awful and in the
middle of a pandemic oh nonetheless
right
the next pandemic is going to be like a
global uh venereal disease
yes ah sick sick story makes me sick
sick story this is like that episode of
friends when ross finds out that condoms
are only like 97 effective
and he's like really furious telling
everyone about it i was just watching
friends this morning i've actually
started to
watch friends while i do my makeup
instead of listening to music or just
like any tv
and it's really enjoyable sometimes i
wish daily pop was on a little bit
earlier so i could watch it as i get
ready for this show kind of like
research you know
yeah but it's on at 12 30. oh they
actually moved it up it's on
at 11 now still doesn't help me no it
doesn't help you but they did make it a
little earlier for you
thanks thanks morgan thanks justin um so
those are the fastest stories that i do
feel as though you needed to know
a lot of baby news and for those who are
trying not to get pregnant and using
condoms
be careful as well be careful careful as
well our vietnamese toasters
be careful um okay let's dive into the
tv recap segment because that's truly
what we came here to do today that's
what we came here to do let's start with
selling sunset because you finished it i
finished it today ago you finished this
last night
tell me what your thoughts were so my
thoughts are the same as they were last
time you saw me like i
absolutely worshiped the ground that
christine quinn walks on
i will say like obviously my heart has
softened towards christelle
100 um what she went through was going
through was just completely sad and
seems unfair i understand that people
are upset with davina for saying there
are two sides to every single
so [ __ ] so [ __ ] and so uncalled for
and and something that you say in the
privacy of your own home if that's how
you feel
right but to like continue down that
road
and i mean i i think i want to say i
understood
maybe what she was trying to get out and
i think this is what one brother jason
was saying too where to
which is like you never know what's
going on yes
behind closed doors i feel like chris
davina and even christine's like
inclination to want to hear just inside
and take his side it's like
justin's not your friend right and maybe
krishna's not your friend but she's the
person in your life where you
she's your co-worker where you even know
about this relationship or or have a
horse in this race
so you're you need to take her outside
yeah of course i think that
davina was way more guilty in that
situation christine was like getting
married and like didn't really care and
just christine talk [ __ ] like just to
talk [ __ ]
yeah and she was like davina came up
with a plan like it was so strange
yeah and i think christine likes to play
devil's advocate and just like
say and really say what she thinks but i
think ultimately she would feel badly
but
i think davina just like kept on like
christine had that conversation once in
her house when they were like
all sitting around talking about it also
christine did not say that to crochet
like there's a difference of course
there's a difference um also it was
getting frustrating for me because i
really really like amanza but her
blind spot is like her inability to just
stay out of things and like she's so
defensive of mary and like we love a
loyal friend but
i literally despise mary she's one of my
least favorite people so like amanda is
just being brought down
by mary and she has to stop and she was
being a bodyguard no she uh she lost me
yeah and yeah mary it's so crazy that
like this whole show is like people
fighting about mary's friendship and
mary's listings and i'm like
mary who she's so like irrelevant she's
so irrelevant every time i see
like hear about mary i'm like who first
of all she doesn't
she doesn't seem like a mary i think her
name should be heather i know i think
her name should be just like
gina no like she's not a mary so it's
it's confusing to me i figured out who
amanza reminds me of
okay remember from like season one real
housewives of orange county
joe yes i got that one too she reminds
me of her i don't know joe well enough
to be like reminded of her
she gave me a little joke also someone
said that amanda reminds them of
robin from the palaton instructor and i
think that's also a really good call
i think that these are all good calls
but it's just like it's so weird
i feel like a lot of times i watch
something and i figure out who someone
reminds me of but like this show is just
full of people
who remind me of other people yeah it's
actually kind of strange it's
really strange i mean the bowling balls
bring me back to my youth my bowling
league
stuff i can't those guys are actually
like pretty smart it's annoying how they
um
really favor mary and like of course you
can't even see it and jason like
obviously
is like still in love with mary but not
ready to come in and i think in like
five years they'll totally get married
it's so weird no it's so strange and
also like what is the dynamic between
jason and brad i think jason's in charge
because even when i watched um the intro
on like the first episode i thought it
was weird how jason said hi i'm jason
openheim this is my brother brett just
kind of like
setting the tone for who's in charge
well you think about them way more than
i did no i do they're involved like a
decent amount they're not like lisa
vanderpump like who's they're
at every party oh yeah they they are
and i think like the oppenheim group it
is what i think it is like pretty
successful endeavor yeah no and the real
estate part of it although i presume to
be like largely
uh fabricated is actually really
interesting i mean la
real estate is such trash like
i don't think i could ever live there
unless they literally had 40 million
dollars for that hillside
plaza you would want to live at that one
the one at the top of the hill do you
know how
like no other houses near me literally
like these other [ __ ] no but like
houses oh of course but i'm saying like
in the show the houses are
on top of each other you're paying four
million dollars for no backyard to
literally be
you could see into your neighbor's
shower yeah no but these new houses that
like mary showing in beverly hills
i'm about that okay but even that 19
million dollar one with the tennis court
and the pool
um that jason and mary were showing
their clients was so sweet that needed
updated bathrooms yeah yeah
yeah it was so nice 19 million dollars
they were like pretty much on a main
road and the houses were so close the
neighbors on both sides were like
a couple inches away like 18 million
dollars no it's insane you can't get
your own plot of land
that's insane insane it was such a crock
of [ __ ] like i actually think for the
house of my dreams i need 30 million
dollars i think you do too
that's what i'm saying um the one thing
about krishel that i wanted to talk
about
was before the divorce i was like really
hating her and the divorce definitely
like you
you can't help but feel bad for her and
i actually thought her sister was so
sweet and like when she gave her a
facial it was just like i was gonna cry
it was like so so so sweet no it was so
sweet i wanted her to stay in st
louis me too and never for one second
did i think rashad was like acting like
her tears were real her pain was real
like i totally
really really felt bad for her and i
just have to say i didn't realize but
she
exclusively went by christelle hartley
and now on dancing with the stars on
instagram she's krishelle stouse and i
just have to say like
i have so much respect for that like you
marry a celebrity like you keep last
name it's like a parting gift like
because then forever you're known like
yeah i'm connected to hollywood like
and i just the fact that she didn't like
really changes how i think about her
like i have so much respect for her no
when i started watching this show
i like i only know her as kirchelle
strauss right right and so
i didn't even know that she went by
hartley and she really made that change
so quick and she made it stick so i
i totally agree i think that was very
impressive we have to talk about the new
girl also this season
who amanda's wigs they were so
bad yeah and i think she's probably like
the most beautiful girl in the office
and she just i think wanted to like
level up her style and her wigs were on
so
they were good wigs but they were on so
poorly and then every time she was in
her confessionals where she had
her own hair i thought she looked so
much better yeah
um so maybe she'll see herself on tv and
like and
switch it yeah yeah no i totally agree
all right so she couldn't sell that
house i was like just this is pathetic
no
like the lateness i actually like can't
i i can't relate but i did feel like
that scene with when heather asked her
to show her the house
and amanda like did it which was the
nicest thing and also sold it she did
deserve a piece of her commission
unless a lot more goes into being a
listing agent than just showing the
house and maybe that's true i i don't i
really don't know that much about real
estate
um and i've also realized like it would
be the job that i would be the absolute
worst at i agree
it's that job i agree um
i didn't know how i felt about the fact
that she was late and like heather was
like then you shouldn't have gone
i felt two ways heather are you [ __ ]
kidding me like this girl did you a
favor but also a manza 30 minutes
okay 10 minutes i can understand you
have kids 30 minutes
and when that happened like i was still
really out on heather and really pro
amanda so i was like
excuse me but now i i don't know 30
minutes late that's really bad to leave
someone waiting like
and it wound up being the person who
bought the house the group being divided
into three and three and like amanda
being on the wrong side
really really bothers me and like turned
to vina i just need to switch because
divina's just the worst and like but she
would net but that's the point like
davina is the you know the bone barrier
for
that group yeah no i know but she's so
annoying i mean that
scene was actually fascinating where
heather got super pissed and walked out
because they were making fun of the
paparazzi
i just have to say christine was
although maybe they were being a little
mean
they were 100 right paparazzi does not
know where tarik el moussa is at all
times
you have publicists they call they
arrange it that she obviously has a
relationship with us weekly because
every time
they were talking about it it was us
weekly so she obviously has a girl there
that that she knows
she's like hey me and tarik bakes
cupcakes like of course it's planted
nobody
actually cares about tarek and heather
so like the fact that she got so
defensive
totally meant that of course it's
coordinated agreed and like they po
they write up her instagram post and as
news heather is
able to be like you know they're
interested in us but like no she's a
publicist who pitches it like it's not a
big deal
i just own it like that come on i agree
it's so silly
do you think that krishele called the
paparazzi on herself
after the divorce like i actually i know
i have become very cynical about like
every
you know paparazzi photo that we see
because i would say nine out of ten of
them are staged
but like i don't think that she did
here's why i don't think
one because when there's a moving truck
at her house
first of all it actually was really big
news like people were talking about it
two um i could see the paparazzi seeing
the big orange moving truck and just
following it like that doesn't sound so
crazy to me and three
i don't think if she had a choice she
would have left those red ugly curtains
up but it was because of the paparazzi
so i actually believe
100 that it was like real yeah
okay so did i and i'm very cynical about
that as well yeah
okay um christine's wedding oh my gosh
okay christine
she is still everything of the sword i
do not understand how she has less
followers than heather
she does she has 1.3 heather is 1.5
krishell has like 1.8 now
justin has 1.9 so i really want
christelle to have more followers with
justin
hartley oh whoa whoa wait i cannot
believe krischell has 1.3 her instagram
is so premium
christine christine sorry but also
christine didn't have
instagram before the show so she started
at zero whereas like i'm sure
christopher
had to come up with a hundred yeah but i
mary has
1.1 and davina has 155k
that's like aesthetic people hate her
that's pathetic oh did you see
i've now been like recatching up on
stuff damina also like lied about her
age she's like not in her 30s she's 42.
oh no i didn't see that but like the
daily mail like uncovered her birth
certificate or something oh my god
that's crazy no i was just catching up
with everything christine has said and
done
since the show ended and i feel like her
and christelle are in a really bad place
i sent you an article a page six article
where christine just like
had word vomit and just like said a
million things about rochelle and like i
don't think
they were male intended but like if i
was rachelle i would
if i were shelly i'd be really [ __ ]
pissed and i think that she is yeah um
the wedding was although not my p
particular taste
like i actually really respect people
who have like a unique style on their
own point of view even if it's like not
at all like what i would do
so i mean every wedding is really the
same and i can say with certainty i've
never seen a wedding like christine's i
thought the snow was incredible
i actually liked the black dress and the
fog like it was not
my personal taste but it was beautiful
it was
incredible agreed my personal taste is
not that gothic vibe
but it was done like in that way
so beautifully and it was frustrating
that they didn't focus
on the actual wedding more because
that was an a million dollar wedding
yeah she spared no expense it got the
same level of coverage as mary's
who we found out also was already
married to romania this was for show
ceremony and like
this was a an entire production event
like
and also she did she was less stressed
than mary and obviously she had a
wedding planner but like
mary spent so much time like being so
stressed and frazzled about her
backyard wedding that she was already
married and like christine put on like
didn't mention it once
the oscars of weddings and i feel like
her wedding didn't get the respect that
it deserved
and i actually read an article where
christine said when she watched the
episode she was crying because she hated
the way that they portrayed it because
they really just like focused on
cocktail hour her co-workers
and the snow and um
i would have been upset if i were her
too because like even though we got to
like see the wedding
i feel like not a big enough deal was
made about like how absolutely stunning
and and sensational and unique and
perfect it was i agree i could have used
like a whole spin-off episode of the
wedding it was because he needs her own
show
i agree she's on another level she
should be on real housewives of beverly
hills
yes i have read like articles that she
said that like that's what she
wants to do with her life but like how
would her and erica jane be in the same
room together
i actually think their energies would
complement each other er they're kind of
different they look so
they look so similar and they dress so
similar but i actually feel like they're
kind of different erica jane is not
[ __ ]
yeah she's actually kind of quiet i
guess but i also feel like christine
and also erica jane like thinks of every
thinks about every word that comes out
of her mouth before it does and
christine is actually the completeness
and then like she'll say what she thinks
and what she means and if she doesn't
feel that way a little later she'll
apologize which is my favorite quality
of hers and it doesn't get enough
respect they're just like
they treat her like ramona like the
sorry tour when it's like no she's
actually in the
total of the three seasons apologized
twice both times i felt it was very very
sincere
and nobody believed her both times like
why would she keep apologizing to you
[ __ ]
yeah so it's very interesting i feel
like now the
the teams are changing i saw that
heather was like in newport with i saw
that too
um the other side and also heather and
tarik are engaged if you even just
glanced at her instagram once like the
last 50 posts are
like right after we got proposed it was
like it was so crazy
it's literally like a parody i mean her
ring is eight carats it's
huge it's eight characters she said yeah
i mean my favorite number i'm like yeah
my favorite number is 15. like
one thousand oh wow i didn't even i
didn't really look at the ring
yeah her instagram page is like a parody
of a person who just got a agent yeah
it's like
it's a lot it's a lot and you know what
i i liked heather for a brief moment
just because she was so blindly loyal
and obsessed with christine
but if you take that out of the equation
she's so lame and
like a dope yeah also how come we never
saw tarik on the show like why didn't he
was at the wedding he was
yes i saw it on her instagram she said
you might not have seen him on camera
but tark was at the wedding
why doesn't he like and justin hartley
was apparently
at a few things in the previous seasons
because um
christine and davina were like when we
saw him here he was so nice to us
so i read more into that and they were
talking about the critics choice awards
and i think things that were not filmed
i don't think he came within like
three inches of netflix yeah yeah i
agree even though this show has become
respectable
the first two seasons it was like oh
this like reality show my wife it was
like embarrassing for him
and now he's like that's probably why he
got divorced because he's like he's on a
cable show he's like my wife's doing
like a trash reality show now it's like
bigger than this
my how the tables have turned my mind
next thing you know this is us
cancelled poof gone that would be a
dream justice for krishna that would be
dresses for rochelle that's really why i
wanted to show the week
yeah she actually looked beautiful this
season she definitely got like some
fillers but i thought she looked amazing
yeah um so that's that on that season
four i'm not sure when it's coming but i
think they're filming it now because i
saw that rochelle was like
showing houses in like full glam oh
right and
so i hope there's a quickish turnaround
me too now i'm like on the
selling sunset train oh for sure i'm
really excited for the next season
and hopefully i i hope that it's soon
and i just hope that christine's there
and i i still love her so much
me too even though she is like beyond
like she's too good for the show
oh totally but i just want to like make
clear like everyone's head like just
wait
your opinions will change yeah i just
want you guys to know like i'm ride or
die
at this point we've reached the tipping
point where nothing she says or does i
will ever
feel differently about it right now it's
like not even so much whether i agree
with her decisions
it's like i don't care don't care like
she's really
reach at eschon of like really like five
people in this world who
who like i'm just unapologetically like
supportive of yeah
um real housewives of new york finale
was so
boring like it was just not a season
worth three reunions
bear i would say barely two usually the
third reunion is like
full of like the real meat and potatoes
it was so boring literally talking about
sony by sonia morgan for 30 minutes like
it was just a nothing burger from a
nothing season and to be honest like
even with the real fights and like the
real meat of it like
dorinda is imp she's impossible to watch
it's someone who
refuses to take accountability just digs
their grave
digs their grave digs their grave like
says like i was in a bad place
so apologize that's fine we've all been
in bad places like it was just
infuriating for the actual like good
parts of the reunion
she's a horror to watch like it's so
unenjoyable she's a nightmare i actually
like after last night's episode i can't
stand her she made me like
really really support ramona which is
how you know she's so unreasonable
yeah and it makes but like i'm that's
why i'm glad that they announced before
the reunion started airing that dorindo
would be gone
because i think that if they knew people
were watching it through the lens of
like she might still be about here
it's it would turn you off completely
i'm also i also think it's actually
really really good for leah that
dorinda's leaving because leah is like a
fan favorite
but i literally she's like being brought
down she's so
blinded by her friendship with joranda
like she is known for being like funny
and odd like very bethany like on the
ball commentary
kind of moral compass like and when she
says jorina never hits below the belt
but ramona does i'm like
what [ __ ] show are you watching like
it was just so
void of any logic or reasoning and
if jorinda had continued and leah would
have continued to be like her friend and
supportive like it i think it would have
been leah's downfall because
you you sleep with dogs you get fleas a
hundred percent so leah should be really
grateful that dorian is not returning
she should be um the best part of the
episode was watch wrap inside did you
see bethenny doing one-on-one
no oh my god it was incredible first of
all bethany looked
unbelievably beautiful i've never seen
her look so beautiful in my life and she
was like just wearing
a tank top and jeans like she looked so
stunning she was really leaning into
house she like knew a lot what was going
on she didn't pretend like she hasn't
been watching she's friends with joranda
she knew a lot of like the tinsley drama
and she is just like my queen
forever and ever she was amazing like
she just
looked amazing she looked so happy and
you want to hear something crazy
yeah she's still married what
beth andy was like are things are going
so well with paul like you think you're
ever gonna get married she goes
i'm still married to jason
how is that possible they're still going
through it what's there to go through
i don't know he's a [ __ ] nightmare
that's
crazy lunatic that's crazy what else did
she say
um she was talking a lot about um like
season one she was showing her
memorabilia
she actually has like the first gold
apple that was like on the
table at the first reunion and everyone
signed it um and she had this like andy
warhol style
um portrait that they sent her and she
was like when they send it to me i was
furious i'm like i lived in a tiny
apartment like what the [ __ ] was i gonna
do with it
but now bless you but now um
it's like her favorite relic and she
spoke a lot about scary island how she
was like a survivor and it was like this
great moment for her because she had
been seeing this craziness in kelly and
like nobody had been singing in and it
was like
frustrating she's trying to show people
then kelly showed everyone and it was
like bethany was vindicated
this is what i've been trying to say
yeah so it was um what'd she think about
this season what do you think about
tinsley well she's
just she told dorinda like she said that
andy asked like ramona said on the
reunion that like you've been in
dorinda's ear and
bethany's like i'm really busy actually
like i donated 20 million to ppe
supplies
i ran a business i just launched my
podcast that's why she was on the show
promoting her podcast
um so i wasn't coaching to brenda but
she did ask me for advice before the
season started
and during the reunion and before the
season started i told her just to forget
about the tinsley stuff like
i told her just to be cool not let it
get to her and just like move on
and of course she didn't listen to me
and i told her to do the same thing in
three union and of course she didn't
listen to me
great yeah she said she keeps in touch
with dorinda and sonia and like radio
silence from everyone else
interesting that's so crazy about luanne
like yeah it's radio silence because
also andy played a game like dude you
regret it and it was like things she did
on the show that she regrets and of
course they brought up the tipsy girl
horrible conversation in bethany's
office
and bethany said no but she regrets her
delivery not her message
yeah when they replayed that last night
when they played like a montage of
sonia's failed business ideas like
it was so painful to watch when
so when bethany called her a cheater
brand and sonia was like
i just thought i could have you know
some success oh my god it's [ __ ]
pathetic it was
literally the saddest scene and the
housewives i was really
nervous for when you get there and
you're weak rewi i don't think i'll make
it all that way i think i was going to
stop like near like heather thompson
and kristen take me like i don't need to
watch kristen take men okay
okay um so yeah i really hurt my heart i
don't really have anything to say about
the reunion it was really really boring
i don't i didn't have much to say either
it didn't require three parts like we
literally had the conversation about
dorinda already so like did you just
we had it in part one like yeah like so
why didn't we put the thing to bed but i
did think it was interesting how they
made a point to say like
that everyone now is on pretty like fine
terms with ramona like her and leah made
up and so
that gives ramona a pathway to the next
season yeah
and i think that's good
um also bethany said that she watched
the part of the reunion where
um they were talking about leah getting
on the show and she said i want credit
like i sent you leah not and 30 other
names and seven other names and i
followed up
and casting asked me for her contact
information and i gave it to her
so like she wanted credit for leah oh
okay but she said she hasn't met leah
yet
but so then how was she so gung-ho about
her i have no idea interesting
also when sonia said that her and ramona
would be having two-for-one um martinis
at the burger heaven
like i literally wanted to cry actually
the cutest thing burger heaven which is
right by sonia's apartment i actually
think they might have closed because of
the pandemic
i have to double check but i think i'm
yeah i think it might have been one of
the many businesses to go out
confirmed yes that was that's very very
sad they had the most amazing curly
fries
and apparently martinis i didn't even
know they had a bar
no me neither she probably exposed them
for not having a liquor like really
sad wow yeah so there is like
there's a foundation for next season but
like they have got to turn it around
they've got work
to do painful painful season yes and
bethany pretty much confirmed
that there is that uh the new housewife
because um
bethany was saying amongst the p she's
been sending andy people when she's on
the show off the show
she like kind of acts as like a like an
executive producer she's like she really
wants the show to succeed
she's always sending names of people she
thinks are interesting she said i've
sent so many african-american people
who might not have been right or the
timing wasn't right so i'm really happy
that you guys are
doing that that's what she said got it
kind of confirming what we were
reporting on this week oh that's so
exciting
yeah she was just she's such
tv gold like she was just being so funny
and so beautiful and so charismatic and
so charming
and i have to watch it i had to
philanthropic you know she sent a
million has well so andy also played
this game like
what would you ask them because she's a
podcast
a host now and it's like what's the
first um question you would ask these
people and there's like kelly benson or
whatever
and then there was governor cuomo and
bethany was like do you know like i was
the one who gave you a million hazmat
suits like at the height of the pandemic
when like there was no supplies in new
york like do you know that it was me
like am i on your radar
that was her question which i thought
was really funny oh interesting that's
so funny okay i'm gonna watch it
it was good just like recap the whole
thing yeah there's literally nothing
else for you to watch you don't know but
i watch it i want to just like get her
vibe you know
um so yeah that's keeping it up oh
keeping up
it was a good episode it was really good
like it was such an interesting time
even though i found it to be
and i thought that even though like i
don't really want to watch coronavirus
programming
um like in the beginning i was like
excited to see like what you know
reality shows when i thought it was just
going to be short but like now going
back to that time like really is like
ptsd
oh that's funny i didn't have that
reaction i actually found it fascinating
to see
if i could like see how we all spoke
about coronavirus before we knew it was
a real thing like it's actually like
interesting to see because we've never
been in a pandemic before like we just
brushed it off like we're probably we
probably didn't take it that seriously
if i listen to some of our conversations
from february
so i thought it was just interesting to
see how the world spoke about it like
everything happened so fast you know
it was a one one minute it wasn't a big
deal and then next thing you know we're
all home for three weeks like yeah
it was just so crazy and it happened so
fast so actually that was fascinating to
see how
people in california and europe were
just like talking about it before it was
really a thing
yeah well it was a thing but before like
the stay-at-home
orders but yeah the like news
stuff and then scott and chloe like
literally didn't go because of it
it was really interesting and so i think
we're getting like really close to like
when they
have to start staying at home because i
think that was like the
and last week of february first week of
march i think that's when we went to
light also remember we were on the plane
and we were wearing masks yeah
and we were doing it like i at least was
like ironically
no it was like super top of mind enough
for me oh for me it was
but anyway so it is interesting to see
how they e-channeled it i thought that
the prank with
chris was like so [ __ ] funny so funny
by the time
like and chris is such a good actress
which also makes me like nervous that
yeah you know she's always acting
on the show because it's weird when they
have to do their interviews and like
talk about their point of view
but before at this point you know and
it's like i don't want to watch you guys
act because it shows me that you can
right and that you might be acting at
other times yeah but i like
to be honest some of the prank
storylines like are not always my
favorite but i thought
this one was good even when chris was
the victim and then when they turned it
around on kim it got even better
and it was super i mean it was super
funny and it wasn't the worst plot of
the episode
the dog was oh yeah the dog was but i'm
so obsessed with corey gamble
like me too oh my god i started
following him on instagram last night
and i just like i love him so much
i literally ship him and chris like
forever i love
how he is with like the other girls and
i just think
he is such a wonderful man me too and
partner
and partner and i just i love him so
much and that's really where i
landed on this episode and i also felt
like i loved the paris content
kim and northie kim getting into that
latex outfit like i
how did she not literally start
profusely sweating i have no idea
it was unbelievable and then she like
stayed in it all day they couldn't pee
till two o'clock
that was so crazy so crazy but it was
really cute seeing kim in north because
like kim has like a whole other
personality when she's talking
like she's literally camper and
counselor yeah and it was
like so it was so fun and when kim
started crying
when north was performing like i
actually got choked up because
i don't know there's just so many
different versions of kim's and like
honestly sometimes i forget that she's a
mom like
i know she has a million kids but like
she's so many things and then when she
was just like
she's always the center of attention so
for like her kids to be the center of
attention she got all choked up i
thought it was really sweet
really sweet and i loved north's
performance like i
i i'm such a big fan of norway's worth
of north and her work yes i really am
and i loved how like obviously you know
she went up there
and she did her thing of course and no
one was trying to say like
challenge right but they were like the
bravery the
great it's like it's such a big deal a
child to go and do that and like
i completely agree and then like at the
end shouting out penelope who was like
in the stands was so sweet
no the whole thing was just so cute it
was honestly a really really good
episode
and i actually think that given all the
news that's been going around about kim
and kanye's marriage i actually feel
like
it was an episode like that the kimye
stands needed just like because they
were so in love in the end they were
just like being such good parents and at
the end of the day all they really cared
about was north's happiness like
it was sweet and it was what the kimye
kids needed yeah but i feel like the
kimi
stands like myself like were unbothered
by the rumors yeah no
there have been rumors about them
forever and i feel like they always
happen when kanye's tweeting like the
correlation is right there um and
nothing's happened so
yeah it was really a really good episode
yeah it was good um i just love them so
much like i just love them so much oh my
god
and when they were all at nobu um kylie
was drinking lily martini i know and i
just like love watching them drink and
kim was like ordering drinks too
yes mango martini and i also feel like
we talked about how did we talk about
how like they're always that nobody
in like paparazzi photos and it's like
who eats there that often
but i think it's because they get that
room and they can film yeah so i really
feel like every time they're there like
they're filming premium content for us
and i think it's i don't know the l.a
scene at all but i do think it's close
to calabasas
malibu is yeah interesting i have no
idea where calabasas
is like the valley i don't know is it i
think
i don't know i don't know either we
should know now by selling sunsets no
but they haven't ventured into calabasas
yet
but that's where the money is hidden
hills
yeah similar i think interesting
people who are listening who live in la
are like these [ __ ] dumb [ __ ]
yeah no i haven't like figured out the
topography there yet
but i'll get a map okay good for you
yeah
um now is that all we had to recap now
that is all that she had written okay
thank you guys so
much oh wait program before i do that we
will not be in studio on monday it is
yom kippur to all of our jewish
followers i hope you have a really
easy and meaningful fact
for all of the non-jewish toasters we
will be back on tuesday and we'll
probably be looking
so dead in the eyes because we haven't
eaten for 24 hours but we
will have just feasted yeah but still
it's that look in your eyes
never goes away um so just no show
monday reminder about that thank you so
much for listening to the morning toast
millennial morning show where we go live
oh [ __ ] thank you so much take it from
the top
[ __ ] thank you so much for listening to
the morning toast the millennial morning
show where we deliver the fast five
stories that you need to know
every morning monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we are
also available as a podcast and we're
podcasting we found so spotify itunes
stitcher public radio i already know
cats box all the places we are now also
available on amazon music so find us
wherever you find your podcast
type in the morning toast and make sure
to leave a five-star review about how
beautiful stunning and smart we are
have an amazing weekend to all of our
jewish followers have an amazing fast
um i mean as amazing as it could be and
we'll see meaningful have a meeting
we'll see you on tuesday goodbye
you